well hey everybody it's movie
retrospective time
here's one that i had been wanting to do
for quite a while i've never seen this
one ever since i saw this back in the
late 80s on cable
and i remember quite liking it but then
i didn't see it again for a very long
time and then a few months back i saw
that it was available on toby and it
still is as of this recording this is
the 1986
horror comedy
vamp
now
uh probably the biggest selling point of
this is grace jones oh she knocks that
apart and i kind of feel like i kind of
wish they had done more with her because
they did i mean you know you get grace
jones in your movie
i mean you want to utilize that as much
as possible yeah um so she's not in it
as much as maybe the marketing would
have had you believe but
when's the like the brief times that she
is in the movie she makes quite an
impression
kind of like a female mr barlow if you
saw uh salem's live she just she does a
dance she appears she kills a bunch of
people she doesn't say a whole lot but
it's a great character i don't think she
says anything she says anything i don't
think she has any lines she's completely
meat when she first appears
you know we grew up we grew up seeing
this kind of stuff you know this is 80
stuff and
when she first appears she appears on
stage doing a number in a strip club
where she does this dance and she
appears in a white face basically she's
got yeah
why looks like a goth girl with white
makeup blue contact lenses like ronald
ronald mcdonald red [ __ ] wig and
she starts taking her clothes off and
she's got this white pattern
painted on her you know by keith herring
yeah it looks really cool and when you
see her in white face you realize how
kind of like scandinavian her bone
structure is i mean she passes for a
white girl
dad uh
with the hair and the white makeup and
the contacts and everything but uh she's
great in this great and
i wouldn't call her goth but she was god
friendly god god people [ __ ] liked
her she she called herself and i think
rightly so a neo-cubist
everything she did was real [ __ ]
and it's got a lot of cool visuals a
little stuff that she would wear like
japanese looking cubist looking [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
kind of chinese and japanese mixed
together with
art deco and she's got a really cool
style man [ __ ] grace charles was the
[ __ ] i kind of feel like she's one of
those
you know and i and i heard somebody else
i think it was on uh grumpy andrew where
he was talking about this and he said
grace jones seems like one of those
people she is still alive actually she's
in her 70s
but um she's one of those people who
saw her whole entire life as performance
art yeah you definitely see so she comes
across in in a similar way to how david
bowie did but maybe like even more
extreme she comes across as like
otherworldly yeah america didn't get
enough of her she was jamaican
and that being part of like british
empire she was more in the european
scene so she was hanging out with europe
european i can see how europeans would
be kind of more into this kind of thing
because like i said they did put her in
a few movies she was in uh view to a
kill
she was in conan
and uh you know and they and they
utilized her well there but i kind of
feel like particularly in this
which i would have actually liked to
have seen her in a straight up horror
movie rather than this which is kind of
like mostly a horror movie but has some
comedic elements in the same way that
maybe fright night did although this
isn't nearly as good as fright night but
this has some similarities with fright
night too and you know we might as well
get this out of the way right now if you
are a big fan of
from dusk till dawn 1996. um this is
pretty much the same story and quentin
tarantino acknowledged that he went so
far i believe as to ask the producer of
this movie uh donald borchers
if he would be okay with him like uh
having a production credit on from
duskill dawn because he basically was
like well this is vamp is where we got
the idea
uh for from duskeldon because the the
story is essentially exactly the same
the tone is good like fright night and
salem's lot kind of mixed together
the makeup in this reminds me very much
of fright night it's not as i said this
isn't as high budget i feel like or the
production value isn't quite as high you
could tell this is a lower budget than
fright night which had come out the year
before
but the vampire makeup is very similar
and when you see grace jones her
character name is katrina she's like a
an ancient egyptian vampire goddess
queen essentially and uh when you see
her at the very end like before she's
dispatched uh her makeup i was like wow
that looks almost exactly like the
makeup for mr barlow from the tv version
of uh salem's lot from 1978.
so they obviously use that though
because you don't know grace is bald so
she looks like mr barlow when she goes
full vampire yeah because she had like
the big eyes and they did like the same
kind of mouth situation and uh all that
kind of stuff and i think grace is maybe
five eight
but she said she was so thin she looked
a lot taller real spider isn't it funny
that like i was just reading a few
minutes ago uh roger ebert's uh
contemporaneous review of this yeah and
he was talking about how you know would
have been cooler if they had to put
grace jones in the movie more and he
said i saw her at a party once and he
said the same thing he's like i was
expecting her to be much taller she's
not but she's not she's just real she
gives an impression of being very she
and she gives an impression of being
very imposing as well but there's like
she's not any taller than that
yeah something like that so a little bit
taller than average for a woman but not
super like i had the idea that she was
like six foot two yeah she looks like
she's six one you you think she's like a
woman with a size 12 foot or something
you know but no she's not she she's a
little bitty things when they sh they
showed her in a in a shot just for a
second i think they kind of accidentally
used that shot because she looked great
in it
but you see her next to a guy one of the
male actors and she's smaller much
smaller yeah she's like a little bitty
thing compared to that guy which is
strange because she has a real powerful
presence to her oh yeah and she was
always like that you know she was
hanging out in the scene and you know
she dated dolph lundgren and a bunch of
other guys
she ever really only married one of
those guys everybody thought that she
was getting married to everybody but i
think she came out and said she only
married one dude and he was kind of like
i think this guy from turkey or
something oh yeah yeah and nobody he
wasn't even really famous
the rest of them she didn't marry him
she just dated him she was just an
artist type
wild character she's
she would do the [ __ ] she would do the
damn i remember her as a kid she'd be
doing the talk show circuits and she'd
show up and basically like a gown you
could see right through
they had to kind of censor her i think a
little bit
and somebody stand in front of her with
it yeah
she would just laugh it off you know she
was kind of like a nudist she did not
give a single [ __ ] and she would go to
hollywood parties basically just with
shoes on and [ __ ] she didn't care
just like i heard jewelry and shoes and
maybe that could eye
she was a little bit of a nightmare on
the set of this movie because she did
like many like many performance artists
she was basically like well we're gonna
shoot the scene when i feel like uh
shooting it and her very iconic dance
where her character is first introduced
um they didn't know what she was gonna
do yeah they basically just said well
they had the outfit and they had like
the makeup and everything and she's just
like yeah you just like film whatever i
do so it's almost kind of like she was
trying to do a strip tease it's like a
strip tease but it's the weirdest strip
to easier just pretending to give head
to a damn statue oh yeah it was good fun
fact that statue was actually modeled
off dolph lundgren yeah okay that does
surprise me and as i said keith herring
like painted all over it this is
one of the most 80s 80s movies yeah it's
good though it's good though it's good i
mean it has like the super uh you know
super green and fuchsia lighting like
the the fashions and everything like
this so so 80s but a lot of good
character actors but yeah that's what i
kind of love about it it's got the dude
from from blade runner who played taffy
lewis he's a remember we just he we just
ran across that dude in a couple movies
hey he you know you could have a drink
jake's on me pal you know he's in it he
plays it down yeah he was like at a in a
hotel or something like that he's like
he's like in one scene yeah being pervy
and [ __ ] it's good though it's good
and they say that dude was a character
too but back to [ __ ] grace jones she
was in the u.s
she was actually kind of we we knew her
as a model that's not what she was she
was a recording artist and an artist
going back to like 77 in the disco era
big studio 54.
she was famous amongst famous people in
the u.s i don't a lot of people didn't
know who she was you know she's just
some weird chick that would appear but
but celebrities knew exactly who she was
she was
real popular with them she was a little
ahead of her time for the american
market
a tad i think that's what the problem
she might still be ahead of her time
yeah
nowadays that cubism [ __ ] is a weird
artistic people like what but she was
she was gifted she you know she was
crazy and knew how to entertain and that
it wasn't a put on i mean she was
genuinely that weird she wasn't like
pretending to be that weird she actually
was that weird you would think that she
would get along with like david bowie
that's what i'm saying like it's it's
the similar kind of vibe although she
was weirder than him weirder yeah but um
you know what i mean but
yeah but in a good way i don't mean that
so when i say somebody's weird that
doesn't mean it's bad she's just kind of
alien
yeah she comes across as very
otherworldly yeah so like i said uh if
you guys have seen from duskeldon but
you haven't seen this you should totally
check this out because this is
essentially where the uh idea for the
movie came from because check this out
this is what happens in vamp and like i
said this came out 10 years before
from dusk hill dawn
so the first part of the movie is
essentially like a frat boy comedy a
little bit yeah uh so you have two uh
roommates
and they're pledging a frat their names
are keith and aj now these are played by
chris makepeace who i recognized and
then like i looked up his imdb i
recognized him from meatballs do you
remember that movie from 82 i think it
was about like about a summer camp i
remember him from that he was in my
bodyguard as well which i think i only
saw once or twice uh the other guy is
robert rusler
and i recognized him from nightmare in
elm street too
he was also in weird science not a huge
role but uh he was a little bit in that
and he was in uh stephen king sometimes
they come back
so the two of them
are pledging this frat and they tell the
frat uh okay if you let us in we're
gonna you know they're having this party
so we're gonna go get you a stripper
so to do that neither one of them has a
car
so then they press into service the
nerdy asian stereotype kid played by a
getty wat knobby who
most famously probably played long duck
dong in 16 candles at least in this
movie he's still kind of like a little
bit of an asian stereotype but at least
they let him use his real voice like his
real american
ass voice instead of making him talk
like you know what i mean like over the
top uh like he did his long duck dong
but he's in this like wearing
i mean the outfit he wears in this is
just ridiculous and hilarious like that
pale lemon
uh sport coat thing and then it's like a
hawaii is it a hawaiian shirt or some
kind of like crazy pattern yeah so he's
like really nerdy and dorky everybody's
a stereotype it is yeah pretty much and
he has a car and he says okay well i'll
let you take the car
for free
if you pretend to be if you guys hang
out with me and pretend to be my friend
for the week and take me on your little
adventure to go find this stripper yeah
so that's essentially like the first you
know 15-20 minutes of the movie me and
jenny are laughing like strippers
[Laughter]
how many of them you want
i was like is it really this much of a
rig like not well now to be fair
they did uh you know we have to go get a
stripper after he called like a few
girls that he knew
that and was like hey we need somebody
to be a stripper and they all like like
hung up on him um but i was like yeah
you just need a stripper i'm like okay
we gotta like let's let's go down the
list how about some cam girls and porn
stars
you need some of those we got
okay but yeah so we think yeah we
thought that was kind of funny that it
was like this big uh this big this big
[ __ ] rigmarole that was eight or four
right 86. this was 86
so uh so they go down
to
it's not specified where this is i think
they shot it in california in l.a
somewhere um but there's it's almost
kind of like a mythical
type place because wherever the college
is they say that they're out in the
middle of nowhere and then they show
them driving and it looks like [ __ ]
vermont or some [ __ ] like with all these
green rolling mountains but then they
come to the city and the city when they
get there this you know what this
reminds me of too this movie it reminds
me of a little bit of after hours do you
remember that that martin scorsese movie
which i think came out in 84 i want to
say where it's just kind of like this
guy and he's like real straight laced
right and like
he ends up like doing this crazy night
where all this crazy [ __ ] kind of
reminds me of something wild too then
i'm thinking about i'd have to see it it
sounds familiar but yeah so and like
where everything goes wrong and all this
crazy [ __ ] happens like on during this
one night and that's essentially what
this what this is there seems to be a
lot of movies that are kind of like that
though i guess so yeah but that's what
that that's the vibe that this gave me
and like that's what was good i don't
know i don't exactly know which one
you're talking yeah i mean it's been a
while since i've seen it but it just
occurred to me that uh that's kind of
similar
so they go to the city which is kind of
like i said like a mythical sort of city
it's lit like
because i think i made a joke at one
point i'm like man it looks like [ __ ]
mario baba is making a movie in here
because it looks very like it has these
really bright like saturated colors they
use like a lot of green lights and like
uh fuchsia and purple
and just everything looks almost kind of
like
comic booky a little bit
it looks like a dream like type of city
now the first time
that they kind of interact with some of
the denizens of this city which i guess
is supposed to be oh this is like the
downtown area so it's all like seedy and
everything and then you get this
gang
led by
billy drago who i feel like they should
have put him more in this too because
he's [ __ ] weird-looking he's like
he has like a gang of albinos
and at first you think that they're
vampires because one of the girls that
he's with like opens her mouth and her
teeth are all [ __ ] up and they look
kind of like fangs and everything yeah
no she's just a cricket but that yeah
i'm pretty sure that they established
later on that that gang are not vampires
yeah i thought but
supposed to be vampire hunters maybe see
that's what i thought but i don't think
that was really resolved so that's one
thing that i thought was a little
strange that they kind of introduced
this gang and there was probably a scene
that got cut maybe that's what it was
but yeah so they kind of interact with
this gang and they're like running away
from them so they end up at this
nightclub where pretty much
the bulk of the rest of the movie takes
place and it's a strip club so there's a
lot of seedy
you know uh
naked ladies and various
actually yeah well most of them aren't
even half nude most of them are in
things that would actually amount to a
bikini or with a g string i mean you do
get to see titties though there's
titties there's not as much of it as you
think though yeah and a lot of it's
happening far away so you can't see you
know what i mean you can't see the
details and then they'll show women
stripping on on on stage
but really it's a glorified bikini
sometimes they're topless
yeah
but it's it's mostly an illusion
they're and then and but they're there's
top of scenes but they're just really
that big deal and i will say too that i
kind of wish i think this movie only
cost like three million bucks to make or
something like that if i'm not mistaken
um i kind of wish that they had had like
a little bit more money to do like some
cool set design around this nightclub
because it's very you know it's fine but
it's very like workmanlike they seem to
use like the lighting gels and stuff
like that as kind of their main
uh focus so they're kind of which yeah i
i actually kind of like that i really
like those
super saturated like that giallo looking
lighting i'm really having another all
the time 24 7. that's right yeah it's
always on i know i never even
don't even turn the [ __ ] off yeah it's a
yeah i like it it doesn't suck any power
not really no not speak up so i just
like really like the look of that yeah
so they go to this place and then
there's this girl who works there
and she introduces herself as amaretto
that's her stripper name but she's also
a waitress now fun fact i thought that
name sounded familiar that's played
she's played by dede pfeiffer that's
michelle pfeiffer's sister okay i think
this was her first movie all right so
she's kind of like cute as [ __ ] in this
but she approaches chris make pieces
character and insists that she knows him
now at first you were like she's like
she's just trying to get a bigger tip
she doesn't really know that guy she
does though it turns out but you don't
find out
how until later on and it's actually
kind of cute
but she's very very like uh madonna in
this one she's got kind of like her her
kind of
frizzy blonde hair on one side and it's
kind of all in little braids on one side
i think she wears like a big like tiger
stripe
big ass jacket at one point the [ __ ]
leggings and it's just it's all very
like material girl
half the cool girls look like that they
did so that's what i'm saying this is so
like i said this is like the most 80s
movie that i think you might ever see
uh so yeah so they're like okay score we
got to this place there's all these
strippers and so then you know grace
jones's katrina is introduced in this
bizarre ass
uh you know dance that she comes out and
does she's got like the wire
things around her titties and it's just
it's a crazy outfit like she's got like
keith herring like body paint all over
and like this big red wig big red it's
like wedge-shaped yeah it's kind of you
know what now now you're thinking about
it it's kind of like an african
um wig
you're like from from like you know uh
you know like off an african sarcophagus
yeah because she's supposed to be like
an african queen yeah because they do
show later on like in her dressing room
yeah egyptians in her dressing room they
have like an egyptian like a sarcophagus
thing there's except it's kind of like
her face so they're implying so they're
implying that she's like thousands of
years old
because she has like so all of these
strippers and all of the people that
work in the club are either vampires or
are thralls yeah um i have to say too
that the guy that's like the mc or the
manager of the club the guy in the pink
uh tux or the pink suit or whatever uh
that guy is great um he's just a thrall
right yeah he's kind of he's essentially
like um
like um what what's his face from
dracula
renfield there you go i don't know why i
can remember that because there's some
point like he has like a little bowl on
his thing with roaches in it and he just
like eats them like they're nuts
that's the shout out to redfield yeah
yeah yeah and uh
it makes me wonder and i had to check
the dates
is this where the idea of [ __ ] akasha
queen of the dab came from
um wait a minute what year did queen of
the damn to the book come out i don't
know because this movie came out in 86.
this is like a movie that anne rice
would have liked she liked
all vampire movies yeah i can't remember
well i mean queen of the damn the book
might have come out before this i can't
really because
interview with the vampire came out in
the early to mid 70s there's a
relationship this was even lifted off a
queen of the damn door or vice versa
you know and and we we know that a lot
of things
out of uh anne rice vampire [ __ ]
concept that she used came from blacula
and screamed black in the screen yeah
and she said that yeah so yeah so we're
not always just making them not making
this [ __ ] up now
so this is a movie you know she
rice would have [ __ ] loved grace
jones so you know she saw this movie oh
i'm sure yeah it's just that i can't
remember like what year the year was
queen of the damned there's a
relationship there but yeah so uh so
essentially the one guy um aj
he goes in the back to go and talk to
grace jones uh aka katrina to try to get
her to come to this frat party and strip
at it uh not surprisingly she decides
she's gonna eat him instead well she
doesn't eat him she just she bites him
and turns him into a vampire yeah so
that's kind of like where some funny
[ __ ] happens later on because here was
another thing that was a little bit
confusing then there's like a chase
because
the the other two guys like the other
two college students are looking for aj
because obviously he's gone missing and
they enlist the help of amaretto the
stripper and so they're looking for
where he went but at one point like
while they're running around oh and
they're also running from that albino
gang with billy drago in it too like
through the streets and through the club
and there's all this other kind of [ __ ]
going on and eventually they twig onto
the fact that the club's all full of
vampires
but at one point
um
keith like falls into a dumpster and
aj's body is in there
but then later on
uh aj comes back and he's like hey
what's up i'm a vampire now
and then but i actually kind of liked
the relationship between keith and aj
like you know their friendship and i
kind of wish they'd gone a little bit
more in that they did it a little bit
like where
aj was kind of like you know look i'm a
[ __ ] vampire now like i just all i
want to do is eat you i don't really
want to do that because you're my best
friend and all this other stuff and i
kind of wish they had done a little bit
more with that they did a little bit
with it but not a lot and i kind of wish
they had done more with grace jones
because
she's in it but
she's not real she's not in it a lot and
i do kind of
enough she's not in it enough i mean you
have grace jones in those fabulous
[ __ ] outfits and the crazy makeup and
[ __ ] like that they didn't like the
vampire makeup and i wish they'd done a
bit more with it and i kind of wish that
like when she gets you know killed at
the end i kind of wish that that had
been like more of a big yeah thing
because it seemed like too easy like how
she got killed was a little bit too easy
she needed dialogue grace jones can have
dialogue she she i don't know why they
didn't give it to her i don't know i
liked it better that she didn't talk
because it was almost like she
well yeah almost like she didn't need to
it was i i got the impression that she'd
been around for such a long time that
she could like convey
her wants and needs to all her thralls
and her lesser vampires like without
even having to say anything like
everybody was just so
uh
you know what i'm saying that's one good
option although i think
being able to speak would have been good
too
because you see where they got that from
is they got that from
from salem's lot yeah with the tv
version of salem's lot
the guy who played barlow really
evidently he wasn't the kind of guy you
could give speaking lines to he looked
[ __ ] great
yeah
uh so they used him and i think he did a
great job but because he didn't have
speaking lines
they had to kind of cut short a scene
that happened in the book where barlow
tests the faith of a priest
with the boy's life hanging in the
balance
and there was kind of there was some
dialogue there and [ __ ] that would
have been much better to have that
dialogue in in that made for tv movie
where that priest was had had to test
his faith and he loses
the [ __ ] parlor eats him
if i remember correctly yeah i mean i
don't know i like i said i'm kind of of
two minds on that in a lot of ways
i think
in this case in vamp and in the tv
version of salem's lot
i kind of feel like it would have made
the character seem less scary if they
talked because it's that demystifying
thing
in the book
um you know in the book salem's lot i
didn't mind that he talked obviously
because you need to convey information
but when you're seeing it i think he's
more scary and more mysterious if he
doesn't talk that [ __ ] was to memory i
haven't read the book in a long long
time and if i seem to remember in the
book the priest loses that bet and dies
but somehow the boy gets away i don't i
don't remember exactly how it went down
do you remember no it's been ages since
yeah i haven't read that since i was a
teenager yeah
so it's honestly it's been so long since
i read that book that i didn't even
remember that barlow talked in the book
yeah he could talk in a book
which i guess makes sense because
stephen king was uh riffing on dracula
and obviously dracula guitar he didn't
say much but he could talk yeah but you
know like what we're saying i kind of
like
that in vamp grace jones doesn't talk
because i felt like she doesn't need to
right okay i just wish that there had
been more of her because she's so cool
looking and every time you see her in
this
she has a different thing going on
and they did actually like i said the
makeup in this is not as
fantastic as fright night because you
know that had a much bigger budget but
honestly i really like the vampire
makeup that they did on her i think it
looked really cool and like i said i
think it was actually absolutely uh
influenced by
mr barlow and salem's live because
particularly at the end when you see her
at the end in her full-on like monster
form when you know keith gets her with
the arrow and then they stake her and
everything like that she looks
just like what was that uh actor's name
reggie
the [ __ ] man now i can't remember what
it was
bernader or something like that i can't
remember what his name was but uh the
makeup looks very similar to that with
the purpose yeah i think they did that
on purpose as well
so it was a good it was it was a good
choice
she looked like a female nosferatu she
turns into a damn nosferatu looks good
yeah and honestly i even kind of like
um when she dies at the end
and they do this weird thing like where
her face
kind of like melts off but it looks like
this weird black tar kind of stuff but
it's coming like it looks like it's
going up instead of down so i don't know
if they ran it in reverse and then it
looks like a skull underneath but not
quite it was wrong a cat or something it
looked like more like a cat it's i don't
know it's hard to explain yeah
and then she like basically turns into a
full-on skeleton and this flips you off
and then yeah and then the skeleton arm
moves
and i was like because i told you it's a
comedy although
i will not that it's not that much of a
comedy though it's kind of
that's what i'm saying i kind of feel
like
it it has a similar kind of balance to
fight as fright night does whereas
fright night
it's a horror movie but it has like
comedic elements in it i think this is
the same thing kind of like reanimator
yeah cause i mean similar
yeah it's kind of like
because sometimes you have a movie
that's just like a straight up comedy
but then it has horror elements in it
this i think is a horror movie
with comedic elements in it yeah because
the college kids are like something out
of down porkies
yeah and it definitely does and in a way
that's kind of like from dusk till dawn
too because from dusk till dawn the
first third or half of it starts out as
kind of like a crime thriller type thing
until they end up at the titty twister
yeah and then it just goes full-on
action horror vampire movie whereas this
starts out as kind of like a frat comedy
yeah and then
it yeah kind of like animal house or
something like that it has like a little
tinge of like horror at the beginning
where they imply that you know these two
kids are gonna get hanged or whatever
yeah but then it's like a fraternity
hazing yeah and it's got a great score
yeah i really do like this score it did
a good job it's it's got good
composition good color palette good
score good act
she says a low budget movie you can't
really tell not really i mean they did a
good job with what they have yeah i'd
put it up there with fright night not
like that and the guy that directed this
richard wank i think this was his first
full-length movie okay yeah he did a
great job and i don't think he did too
many after this i mean i think he did
some like later on like in the 2010s and
stuff if i'm not mistaken
but i've never seen the movie i mean i
just never saw it i don't know why
uh yeah and you could shoot yeah because
you would think i mean
as i said if you're really into like 80s
movies and like i said if you really
like from dusk till dawn then you should
totally see this because this is
absolutely where quentin tarantino and
robert rodriguez got the idea for that
when i was a kid i used to see it at the
video store and i never rented it
because i just didn't like the cover it
said vap and it had
tea the lips and the facts and i was
going that's a chick flick
there's a new cover for it that has that
same cover but then it's got
it's got um
it's oh [ __ ] it's great it's got grace
jones on it and she's in that [ __ ]
stripper outfit yeah well she's not a
stripper not really but yeah in her
opening
she's like it's like goth white face
with the red wig and i read it i was
like oh yeah yeah it looks because you
know what i mean i didn't know who was
in it i didn't know what it was about
i didn't understand the motif there's no
photography in the original cover it was
just a black and purple
with like vap and then fangs i think
with lips it just kind of just red it
was just red and white and black was it
okay it just i remember it looking real
basic
i remember seeing it but now i realized
i never chose it and i should have i
would have liked it yeah just because of
the cover i thought comedy no you know
what you know why now i'm remembering it
there was some cheesy vampire movies out
around that time like love at first bite
and [ __ ] that i couldn't stand at that
time if i were to watch them now they
might be a little bit better but
remember they had even like vampire
parodies going on
remember once bitten yeah with a very
young jim carrey yeah and lauren hutton
is that kind of [ __ ] so i thought
although i like that movie
i thought it was going to be movies like
that so i never i never got it see
that's and that's what i'm talking about
because once bitten
i would call that and i like that movie
actually that's a movie that i would
call a comedy
that had a couple of horror elements but
it's mostly a comedy
this one is mostly a horror movie yeah
but just has funny stuff in it funny
[ __ ] in it it's but it's mostly a horror
movie
um so that's kind of like where the
difference lies i would not and i think
that they marketed this as a comedy yeah
i think even the tagline said like a
frightening comedy or something like
that and i don't i don't think i would
go that far i would not call this a
comedy it has funny [ __ ] in it but it's
mostly a horror movie i would have
marketed it along the lines of fright
night and yeah um reanimator yeah
something like that uh you know that
that kind of stuff more of a horror
movie
yeah you know i would have liked it and
i didn't realize it had so much nudity
in it man if i was a teenager i'd have
been all over that that's right
that's what shocked me that you hadn't
seen this because i'm like not only is
grace jones in this looking badass as
[ __ ] but i'm like there's tons of naked
ladies in it the whole thing takes place
in a strip club we didn't know
we didn't know the whole thing takes
place in a strip club pretty much we
didn't know can i can i just give a
shout out to the one line i love
the guy like the the guy in the pink uh
outfit where he's like uh i'm seeing
he's introducing all the strippers and
the one stripper that was dressed kind
of like a construction worker and he
introduces her saying something like the
was she the like the engineer the
constructor of major erections or
something like that and it's like that
line just made me like laugh
but yeah so
if you haven't seen vamp uh definitely
check it out if you're into 80s horror
sort of comedies just fire any horse and
vampire anything
uh you know and let us know what you uh
think about it it's actually on to be at
the moment for free uh yeah it's pretty
good i mean like i said not the best i
mean it's not as good as fright night
obviously but it's along those same
lines well i mean if you've seen all the
other 80s movies just put this one in
there with in case you haven't seen it
it's along that yeah i feel like this
one gets a little bit uh forgotten about
a little bit you know you're gonna watch
the same old 80 movies over and over
again you know they're they're new with
them go watch it differently
yeah there were ones that were forgotten
that got that were good yeah yeah uh
yeah and like i said right now at least
if you have to be whatever country
you're in uh it's on there for free as
of this recording so go check it out and
uh that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys on the
next one
bye